it's been like this for months
[Applause]
public sector strikes on a scale not
seen for decades
heart in our hospitals schools Railways
airports today the Prime Minister
finally trying to call them off with an
up to seven percent pay offer for
millions of workers I can confirm today
that we are accepting the headline
recommendations of the pay review bodies
in full
but we will not fund them by borrowing
more or increasing your taxes
it would not be right to increase taxes
on everyone to pay some people more an
estimated 5 billion pound pay rise for
Millions paid for through existing
departmental budgets and an increase in
the levy migrants pay for NHS access
today's offer is final
there will be no more talks on pay and
no amount of strikes will change our
decision the PM walking away with a
quick win as teaching unions told
members to accept the offer and call off
Autumn strikes our members have won this
6.5 and won this 900 million and won
these movements on workload that the
Prime Minister has signed up for that's
why I think members should now Bank the
success that they've they've made I'm
saying that this is value to you but
actually you brought in an anecdote
haven't you the government promising
that extra money for pay won't come out
of schools budgets
which unions say are already underwater
still after making uh cuts and looking
at everything very very closely we are
kind of just in line maybe slightly
below depending on actually how the
funds are allocated uh so to be honest
until I actually see the the revenue
come in I'm very very skeptical
[Music]
Junior doctors who've just been
strike rejecting the offer outright this
is another offer that has been imposed
on us without our consent without our
negotiated agreement and it just goes to
show how to touch the government is
when Rishi sunak says they're not going
to talk and no matter how much we strike
I think we're going to see in the future
really if that statement holds up the
truth
after months of Rouse overpay the Prime
Minister has accepted the pay review
body recommendations all too aware that
failure to do so would have prompted a
wave of industrial action and public
anger directed at a government already
20 plus points behind in the polls this
pay deal is further than he initially
wanted to go but I'm told that the prime
minister is hopeful that unions will
meet him halfway but already the signs
are that strikes will continue in some
sectors while the PM is also now facing
questions about where Cuts will fall to
pay for it all
Mr Sun at all hope ending School strikes
will endear him to some voters but he's
far from drawing a line under the
strikes damage in the country and him
bath Rigby Sky News Westminster